for a president accused of inaction
this was a decisive moment today i
authorized two operations in iraq
targeted airstrikes to protect our
american personnel
and a humanitarian effort to help save
thousands of iraqi civilians
who are trapped on a mountain without
food and water
and facing almost certain death america
is coming to help these people he said
desperate iraqi christians yazidis and
shia
forced from their homes seeking shelter
in the mountains
the unforgiving terrain has nothing on
the threat they run from
the group formerly known as isis now the
islamic state
whose message rings far and wide convert
or be killed the u.s says the situation
threatens to become a humanitarian
catastrophe
which is why president obama ordered an
aid drop on mount sinjab
in the early hours of this morning in
recent days
yazidi women men and children from the
area of sinjar have fled for their lives
and thousands perhaps tens of thousands
are now hiding high up on the mountain
with little but the clothes on their
backs they're without food
they're without water people are
starving
and children are dying of thirst earlier
in the day the president met his
national security team to discuss the
situation which is undoubtedly
urgent
outside the white house there were
desperate calls for action
islamic state fighters continue to
spread mayhem and fear
taking 14 towns in 24 hours
they raised their black flag at the
border of the kurdish semi-autonomous
region
as they continue their aggressive surge
towards erbil
the u.s may have authorized air strikes
but that shouldn't be read
as war the president was very keen to
point out that those strikes were to
protect
u.s personnel in beale the obama
administration
mantra is very clear there is no u.s
military solution to the problems in
iraq but
if this is the start of a genocide they
may be forced to stick to their other
rule
that the world cannot sit by and watch
it happen
in irbil nearly 300 christian refugees
sought sanctuary in a cathedral
their persecution does bear the terrible
hallmarks of ethnic cleansing
and their plight could lead the u.s to
act further
but the long-term hope is still that the
divided iraqi government
can save its own country this is after
all a u.s government
intent on ending wars not starting them
amanda walker sky news washington